thank you
[Music]
as if I didn't ask this earlier anybody
here know Whitey never heard of older
who sounds like a bulge it's really
bulging [ __ ] crazy would you rather
be like vulgar vulgar or Bulger like
he's got a bulge that's a that's a good
nickname I think anyways first time I
ever learned or heard about this dude
Whitey Bulger was from the Johnny Depp
movie Black Mass this is Boston
notorious gangster apparently it was on
the uh top 10 FBI Most Wanted list by 99
and was the most wanted person behind
Osama Bin Laden during that era he's a
wanted man that guy well in 2014 what
had happened was he had he he was he was
like caught and convicted earlier and
apparently he was like an informant for
the FBI for like 25 years since the 70s
or something the point is he eventually
gets uh caught and incarcerated and then
in 2018
um he is a high profile inmate that is
transferred to a West Virginia prison
where within that for within that night
he is a bludgeoned to death oh [ __ ] and
then that was basically just like oh
whoa this is crazy like there must be
some hole in the judicial system and
blah blah blah he got assassinated is
that bludgeoned eight yeah bludgeoned a
bludgeoned is that means a blunt force
like somebody in jail was like
[ __ ] still pipe y'all maybe did
it to himself like Jeffrey Epstein but
there's a Twist there's a Twist that
came out uh today actually in the Whitey
Bulger murder case where inmates at West
Virginia prison knew in advance that he
was coming which is something that
people aren't supposed to be privy to so
why would they know that now
they're like ah we knew how could they
prove they knew so inmates at the prison
where James Whitey Bulger was killed new
in advance that the notorious gangster
was being transferred there according to
a transcript of a phone call between one
of the suspects and his mother wow quote
we're getting ready to get another
higher profile person here tonight uh
the student's name is Sean McKinnon and
did he call her ma who told his Ma on
October 29 2018. according to a partial
transcript of the call read by federal
prosecutors in court yesterday
McKinnon went on to identify the
arriving prisoner as Bulger the former
Boston Crime Boss
his mother Cheryl says stay away from
him please according to the transcript
and the call took place at 3 30 PM that
day Bulger 89 arrived at the prison in
Hazleton West Virginia Virginia five
hours later at 8 30 pm and he was found
bludgeoned to death at 807 a.m oh
bulger's death was a stunning security
failure for the federal prison system
the previously undisclosed Revelation
that USP Hazleton inmates were tipped
off to bulger's arrival raises
additional questions about the Federal
Bureau of Prisons handling of its one of
its uh of its transfer to one of the
country's most violent prisons
basically
I think uh the Bureau of Prisons
investigators the FBI everybody like
that is like oh this is crazy it's
absurd that something like this happens
oh no but it's also the most violent
prison in the country it's the most
violent and somebody gave the
information to these inmates that has
now been proven in a five-hour earlier
transcript wow he was sent to his death
yeah that's how he proved it that they
knew yeah but do you think the FBI and
all them were just like yeah let it
happen probably or do you think they're
like we need to get more dirt
well this uh former Bureau of Prisons
investigator who spent more than two
decades investigating inmates for gang
affiliations and other potential threats
to determine where they should be placed
inside federal prison said it's just
absurd that this happened he said he
would have raised holy hell over Bulger
being placed in the general population
of a prison like USP Hazelton so he
should have been protected considering
his high profile everything is done both
from like a notorious gang standpoint to
probably also being an FBI informant
right like so he's a rat pretty much so
they probably made him alive then if
he's an informant too yeah or or like
why would you send a rat to a general
prison yeah yeah second most violent in
the country true yeah they sent him to
his death he did something wrong or they
didn't need him anymore he was 89 years
old they didn't need him anymore
probably yeah so nothing left but frame
to leave and that's why we never had a
podcast from him that would have been a
good podcast that's on red I bet he that
dude got some crazy stories yeah I like
listening to all the mob bosses like now
coming out on podcasts and [ __ ] and
coming out with books and stuff I think
it's the most interesting which one have
you been listening to uh you know that
guy value entertainment yeah he he he
um he always does a ton of different
podcasts
but there's I'm learning about new guys
that I didn't know before because you
know there's like the whole like the uh
what's his name
he's based off of that character from
that movie of uh so all the mob movies
right like the characters are based off
of real mob guys those guys like he
interviews them and then he he
interviews them and like asks them like
what was it really like like in in your
day and all that and then you can just
have here like one or two hour
conversations of like all this and it
just gets crazier and crazier and the
real life [ __ ] is way better than the
movie [ __ ] because it can't be too
graphic in these movies or it's also
very straightforward it's like if you
look at the soft white underbelly where
it's a corrupt cop from New York that
was like a corrupt he was basically like
uh for like 15 something years he was
just collecting uh drug money from the
people that he was gonna bust and then
uh and then he would take those drugs
confiscate him and sell them to other
dealers we just did the same he just did
the same thing over and over and over
for years and years years so it's like
interesting but like also like that's it
yeah and he's like yeah that's it and
then all those all the other cops knew
he was doing it and they hated him but
they didn't rat on him they just hated
him it wasn't yeah rat on a fellow yeah
it wasn't until he like beefed it with
another officer over something totally
different that they ratted him out
whoa whoa so the justice department last
week announced charges against McKinnon
and two Massachusetts men with mob ties
uh fotia photos Freddy gas uh uh Mafia
Hitman who was sharing a cell with
McKinnon and Paul decog cologero who was
a member of the organized crime game how
dare you get my name wrong I'm gonna
kill you sorry speaking at a detention
hearing for McKinnon on Monday
prosecutors describe what the
surveillance system captured inside the
prison providing the most detailed
account yet of the circumstances around
Boulders killing so shortly after the
cell doors opened up on their unit at
6am
the three suspects met in the cell
belonged to uh GS I'm gonna say gay yes
because it's funnier to gayest and
McKinnon six minutes later all three
walked out according to a prosecutor
Hannah Norwalk
de color gero and guess entered Bulger
cell McKinnon sat at a table with a view
of that cell in the officer's station uh
Dakota Gerald and gas remained to bulge
herself for seven minutes after they
left at 6 13 am all three men returned
to the cell belonging to gayus and
McKinnon according to Norwalk she said
the government's case is bolstered by
three jailhouse informants one of them
said to color General who goes by Paulie
told him that Bulger was a snitch
according to Noah Bulger acted as an FBI
informant while he led the largely Irish
mob in Boston from the 70s to the early
90s quote Paulie said as soon as they
saw Bulger come into the unit they
planned to kill him wow because they
knew he was a stitch yeah holy [ __ ] like
you know they do the snitches dude well
actually they just die no stitches
funeral they said the entire unit that
area was alerted that Whitey Bulger was
was coming to that unit wow everybody
was already [ __ ] ready to go
everybody is in it here probably around
a lot of people that Whitey Bulger guy
Dan can you imagine that like the second
you get transferred and you're dead
within 12 hours it seems like it never
ends well for informants it took him
seven minutes to kill an 89 year old man
dude he lived way longer than he should
be being an informant right he would
have been dead way sooner because then
you sell out all your homies and then
but you buy some time and and he died at
89. he was like worth it kill me
bludgeoned me at 89 you know and the
guys that are killing him are I'm hoping
that they're senior citizens too so this
is one one's 55 in the senior award oh
no they're actually oh dude take this
is 36. ah that takes the fun out uh
Young Guns 39. other abuse dude that's
[ __ ] up
we only took six seven minutes so that's
how long it does a rat though I think I
can kill an 89 year old man way faster
dude wow if he was a rat if he was a rat
and I was a monster he was a rat not a
regular 89 old yeah but at that point do
you want to kill him fast though you
know what I mean that's true I think
it's a different mentality that's true
in jail you have a limited amount of
time to get the job I don't have a
stopwatch like all right ready yeah in
jail they like have a shaved off pen
they're just using it to stab 80 times
in order to make sure it work ouch it
was probably meant to be a stabbing but
it was too blunt I don't want to be
dying from a [ __ ] shaved toothbrush
yeah yeah dipped in dipped in [ __ ] you
know they like dip it in [ __ ] yeah yeah
you get infected on top of dying yeah
well because if you live then they want
you to like you know
Jesus they shove it up their buttholes
on accident instead of dipping in the
shits you know there's an easy way to do
that Frank
why you gotta be free why can't it be
Tony James
any of any other notorious other than
[ __ ] like Epstein but like anybody
else big
well
um I don't kind of different thought but
I always wanted to see a happy ending
crime story because they always end so
sad yeah you know like what about what
the crime get they get away yeah what
about the guys that had a life of crime
and and then yeah Cooper that's maybe
like they opened up a bakery and changed
their lives and then they live happy
ever a lot of them still do Bakery
there's never any movies like that
because they the movies always are like
oh you gotta [ __ ] make sure that the
criminal is caught at the end what about
Leo from Catch Me If You Can dude he
works for the FBI now oh he's still a
rat he's gonna have dying like this guy
89. that one documentary with the two uh
the two Goodfellas guys so like Ray Ray
Liotta you know how you ride it and then
so uh uh
uh Rob Robert De Niro wanted to kill him
yeah and then I saw this documentary so
he wanted to kill him and then uh I saw
this document where they reunited those
two and they're both like 70 something
now and then they're just like walking
in New York and they're just playing
chess and he's like hey they forgive me
I'll forgive you man and I was like that
was real yeah it was a real character
the two real ones they face the
character out they're like uh [ __ ] it
it's not like Mike Tyson talking to Mike
Tyson that's tight yeah I was like damn
that's really cool
and then later on the documented cameras
turn off like what the [ __ ] Fork yeah
yeah dude I want to see one where it's
like a dude ever like went to jail he
ended up he did a life of crime he was
tremendously successful [ __ ] happy
family and then he retires now he's in
Florida playing cards with his friends
and it's a good [ __ ] wholesome story
do you guys know what the story
sorry Cooper in the 60s he hijacked the
plane and um there was a ransom for
money they paid it to him he Sky Dove
out of the plane and they never found
him oh I do know your time that's DV
Cooper yeah and then the uh the guy that
has the highest likelihood of being him
uh was a guy that just like lived his
life totally you don't know but no one
knows who that is it couldn't be
confirmed because when they found the
guy who was highest likely to be him
they were trying to press him to admit
it but he never would fully admit it and
he was just a dude that lived on the
like in the marina fixing boats just
some [ __ ] great life he's an old man
yeah and they they connected it to the
point where like this is probably it
might not be but it's the highest and
then right before they could get him to
admitted that he just passed away of
natural [ __ ] is that the documentary
that was on Netflix yeah it's really
good you should watch it yeah that's a
good feel-good story you know what I
mean he didn't hurt anybody he didn't
hurt anybody yeah
that is different we did an article here
about like there's this dude who's
success he was like one of the uh
accomplices to one of the huge Mafia
crime Lords or whatever he's like in the
they're like Italy or some [ __ ] right
yeah and then he got pop moves to Spain
and he opens like a vegetable shop and
he's doing produce produce for like 30
years and then a Google Maps like car
some [ __ ] Drives By gets a photo of him
and then it registers into the [ __ ]
database bro that's that's he [ __ ] up
like 40 years later he had like two
daughters or something I don't remember
but yeah that's how you get you got got
by Google Maps bro that's what sucks
well now everybody's doing we're just
talking about uh two weeks ago but uh
DNA now right everybody cut DNA samples
from the 70s 80s or whatever now they
can [ __ ] ancestry.com that shouldn't
be like you did kill this person even
with no priors you can still get paid
today that's crazy hey boy that was you
yeah we have proof ah you got me science
huh you gotta be freaking science I want
these guys to get away
all the murderers too they're just old
and happy now you know I don't think
they're happy
[Music]
[Music]